[Music]
all right here's some BuzzFeed lists I
saw recently here's one look at this one
24 dogs who regret getting bangs
damn you Zooey Deschanel
what's net what's up next 38 Star Wars
trailer parodies made since 9:00 a.m.
this morning that's pretty much the
entire internet right now look at this
one
11 carats who swear that's what 6 inches
looks like that's just depressing look
at this one 5 Disney Princesses you
didn't know we're Scientologists oh my
God look at this one 18 numbers under
100 I'm sorry let's pause and that's the
shittiest list that's pretty bad that's
just a bad bad list look at this one I'm
not untrue no it's shitty look at this
one right here 12 ways to tell if you're
having sex with Joe Pesci okay yeah I
have 10 most amazing apps that are still
loading that's a boring list for this
one 7 people reading mine comp on their
Kindle didn't know you could get mine
compound 14 zoo monkeys about to toss
some semen at you monkey let's say such
a jerk all right
Kamiya you can yeah is closer little
closer that's just right hold it right
there
15 Timmy's who really are the reason for
their parents divorce
look at that [ __ ]
yeah
[Laughter]
and finally one blackfish fan
[Applause]
you